you're live thank you
good evening and uh welcome to this
meeting of the
strategy resources committee on thursday
the third of february 2022
i am councillor christopher swain vice
chairman of the committee
uh chairing this meeting in the absence
of the the chairman councillor siddal
the
meeting is set up to um
mitigate against covid and despite
recent changes
in general policy we are still bound by
the
rules that um council set in april last
year
so
anybody present here everybody present
here has been
asked to ensure that they have passed a
lateral flow test
with a negative result
and um
everybody is asked to
um
use masks particularly when moving
around um
as
the regulations say
this meeting is being streamed and by
being present you are deemed to have
given your consent to being
on the recording
during each item
members
may indicate that they wish to speak and
when called
please then use your microphone
but switch it off when you have finished
to avoid
complicating the recording system
uh the youtube is dependent on this
correct use of microphones
when you do raise a point please refer
to
a paragraph or
section
if
relevant
and now draw your attention to the
notices on the
order papers
which
concern particularly the
means of escaping in
case of fire behind the stage here and
also the fact that um the levels in the
in the chamber do vary a lot and i
particularly draw that to the attention
of a member of the members of the public
who were pleased to see in the chamber
again after a long absence
as we move to um item two apologists for
absence
um tara
apologies we have
good evening chairman good evening
members thank you apologies chairman
have been received from councillor
siddal and councillor stevens is
attending as a substitute for council
thanks to thank you
thank you
minister of the last meeting which on
pages 5 to 38
of the papers
chairman
councillor morris in attendance please
come in and show okay uh be it noted
then tara that councilor morris is also
present
yes of course chairman thank you
right for minutes of the last meeting
then um
i removed the move the minutes of the
last meeting and
ask somebody to
second
um those minutes
council channel thank you
so does anybody have any question on the
accuracy of the minutes from that
meeting
do we agree then
okay thank you
we'll move on to then disclosure of
interest
members i was required to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interest other peculiar
interests or non-peculiar interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda
having regard to paragraphs five to
eight of the um
six to eight for the code of conduct
from members and do we have any
declarations of interest
councillor stan
uh thank you chairman um just that i'm a
member of essex county council and i
have a number cue in your interest on
agenda item 15.
uh councillor darum
thank you chairman also nom cunary
impress a member of essex county council
thank you
thank you
thank you councillor yeah thank you
chair and i'm peculiar you're interested
in agenda item number eight and i've had
conversations and correspondence from
some of the stakeholders regarding this
issue
thank you
thank you
uh thank you very much also uh item
eight in that i'm uh
uh i'm acquainted with some of the
individuals connected with the barge
operation
i did raise the issue with mr quelch
because of a dispensation from last year
but mr quelch
is satisfied that there is no
further interest to declare other than a
non-pecuniary one thank you sure
um right item five on the agenda public
participation i've been advised there is
no um
item then no um
no personal wishing to
um
take part there or notify that they wish
to
so we moved to item six
um supplementary estimates violence
procurement exemptions and use of
reserves
um
pages from pages 39 to 42
there's a report from the director of
resources
um
i'll pass this over to mr dunsley
this is a regular report to the
committee all items in this report are
for noting on this occasion in
accordance with the financial
regulations
there has been one supplementary
estimate since the last report for
sixteen thousand pounds and this is in
relation to a specialist consultant to
assist with the negotiations of the
waste contract
there have also been three procurement
exemptions which are shown in paragraph
3.5.1
and the reasons for those are outlined
in the paragraph
thank you
does anybody wish to raise a
question on yes council pluckers
yes thank you chair yes items two and
three uh the wi-fi for the uh prom parks
uh yes indeed because they are required
to link in to the existing
infrastructure and they are a key
person to do that because of their
existing connections to the contract so
that's absolutely a single supply in
that respect
in terms of the fire risk assessments we
need to get in with that very quickly
very urgently there's clearly a health
and safety matter involved so i do feel
that that
is very much value for money in getting
the urgency and putting the safety of
everyone first thank you
well we'll move to the recommendations
page 43.
there's recommendations then the
committee consistently reviews this
report
yeah
right two recommendations were
supplementary estimates as detailed in
paragraph 3.4.1 be noted and the
procurement exemptions as detailed in
paragraph 351 be noted
agree okay thank you
we're going to item seven
capital investment strategies for twenty
twenty two two to twenty three and
minimum revenue statement
twenty two twenty three pages forty
three to eighty six
it's a requirement for the council to
have all these strategies in place
and they have been prepared in
consultation with their treasury
advisors
the capital strategy at appendix 1 sets
out the capital expenditure and how this
will be funded
there is no borrowing requirement as
expenditure will be funded from capital
receipts reserve or government grants in
the case of disabled facility grants
the new capital bids are shown in
appendix 2 of the report and remain
unchanged from those reported to the
committee in january
the investment strategy at appendix 3 is
complemented by the treasury management
strategy which comes later in the agenda
and this sets out the council's
estimated maximum investment exposure
and
return
the minimum revenue provision statement
at appendix 4 sets out how the council
will repay any expenditure financed by
borrowing however the council does not
have any and is not expected to have any
underlying borrowing requirement
there are figures in the table in
respect of vehicle lease payments
which for accounting purposes are
required to be defined as a mrp payment
minimum revenue provision
payment so relate to vehicle leasing
rather than an underlying need to borrow
thank you
right
members can we progress through these um
four items whether anybody has any
questions on
um the capital strategy strategy
um in appendix one
sorry no appendix 2 when you get to
appendix 2 please
okay
um move on to appendix 2 then capital
project bids
um any members wish to speak on those
counseling none
um i i'm conscious that i'm new to this
committee and that mr leslie has said
that these issues were discussed in
january
but can i turn to page 50 please at the
top
the service capital bids
mr leslie has previously mentioned
um leasing
uh why why are we why are we replacing
these replacement vehicles
is this purchase replacement
why are we buying vehicles um have we
looked at best value in terms of
uh comparing that to leasing costs over
a period of time please
so the
options are considered around the
vehicles and the best
route
really depends on the vehicle and the
use of the vehicle
these vehicles tend to stay with us
longer have a longer duration
however we do have a lease in respect of
a tractor where we've chosen the route
of leasing that just because of the wear
and tear and repair costs involved so we
assess which option would be the best
option so there's actually a mixture of
both we're not just going down one route
regardless
happy to let it go this time um chair
but i think we do need to uh look at
this in a bit more detail in the future
um thank you councilman
yes it is always um a difficult um which
would say calculations whether to buy or
to lease and
but leasing always has an overall cost
it's greater but um
obviously buying
means
laying out the money sooner
councilor fluco
page 50. so
to charge
um
if we go ahead and do this
if
is
so i think it really does need
um yes thank you as we've got a question
of electric vehicles this is
um
to some extent guessing the future
developments isn't it
in terms of um
climate change strategy and all that
it's it's obviously um the sort of way
to go but it is
open to um doubt just what's going to
happen to electricity charges
when you've got the bulk of vehicles
using electricity
but that's not possible to calculate at
this stage
um
thank you on the car park yes i'd be
particularly concerned about that lane
sliding down the hill
um
yes
my feeling is that any trees there would
be helping to support it but there
aren't many i think it's got to be
proper concrete
pillared buttressing or something
um but i think mr holmes will um verify
what the cost is of not of losing um car
park spaces if we were to
rope off a whole area there
um
there was also a question of whether we
had any um insurance claim on it i don't
know whether
we we got anywhere with that possibility
there may be some recovery on
picture insurance shows the
damage
so it shows
all right okay this council stand
thank you chairman um thank you
councillor fluker um i thought you might
say something about the pontoon so i'm
glad you're not disappointing us and
welcome back
um
it says quite clearly existing pontoon
was installed in 2006 and there's been
no maintenance on there whatsoever so i
actually think i actually was going to
applaud that this council was actually
going to invest in burnham on crotch for
once once in a while sorry mr holmes but
there we go and i think it is i've had
conversations with a with an officer
about the possible uses in the future on
how we can get an income if we can get
it back up to scratch so i certainly
will support
that project it goes without saying my
area of concern though if i do have one
and it is just about the boiler you know
the replacement boiler are we actually
going to at the sports centre are there
going to be new contents in boilers i
mean i've noticed that they're gas does
that fit in with our climate strategy
should we be looking at ground source
heat pumps or whatever so they only last
i think it's due to last 10 years
but i do think we need to be cautious
that you know i can't what was the price
forgive me chairman
31 000 is that good value for money
really
leave leave the burnham on crotch one i
think we'll all agree with that one
but but if we can if we can look at uh
if we can actually look at whether that
is best value for money uh in the
swimming pool please on a serious note
we have to make sure that we're actually
doing to to our strategies that we as a
councillor have signed up to thank you
chairman um
yes um i think um if i defer to mr
holmes on that but the point is that um
it's a question of
potential breakdown and completely sort
of putting the leisure center out of
operation in the near term because so
that's right chairman can i before mr
hams comes in that's not my point my i
know what it why we need to replace it
it's are we actually you know looking at
the future and making sure we replace it
with the correct tech technology
chairman thank you
sherman if i can help um yes we've
looked at the most cost effective way to
ensure that the center keeps running for
this time being this is the most
the least cost that gives us the
reliability obviously we're coming
towards an option around our leisure
center so within two or three years
we'll be looking at the whole centre
again in terms of its future what
investment needs to make in that so i
can take your point do we spend a lot
more money now upgrading a part of the
center or do we do a minimum cost and
then do revisit so i think that the
considered view is we actually go for
the least cost at this time um i don't
believe that will mean we will waste
that money in until three years time but
you're absolutely right we need to look
at the whole centre the way it's been
lit and heated as part of our sort of
potential revamp on that so i think this
is probably the most cost effective way
for right now to deal with it
there are other technologies that come
with a much bigger price and i think it
needs to be built into a bigger package
of measures in the centre itself
this is it's almost counts as essential
maintenance in a way but um as far as
the pontoon's concerned um
is the um
so is the idea of um
of uh replacing a
viable kind of approach to it
chairman yes and we have looked at the
pontoon and just to give reassurance
although we've not spent any money on
maintenance has been inspected but this
is just general corrosion wear and tear
since 2006. so we've commissioned a
report into the uh condition and looking
to see whether this is the most sort of
best value to say replace it or uh
repair it so i think this is the
provision to to do the larger work but
obviously if we could do less we would
do providing it's still fit for purpose
but we will be looking at the best value
option and how to to make sure that it
stays there and we can deal with it
thank you
councillor daryl
thank you chairman i just wanted to give
councillor flukas some some comfort
because i did actually buy a fleet of
similar electric vehicles to the
electric gator and uh they're far less
sophisticated than modern uh electric
cars which i think comes from flicker
hands now
and in fact because they're charged
overnight because they're not used
overnight um in fact they're just
usually charged with a 16 amp commando
socket um and we actually had a row of
13 amp uh and i think they use lead acid
batteries still
in them so they are easily uh
easily and cheaply uh serviced and and
also in respect of the andrews boiler
again i i had caused to install um a
boiler for a swimming pool complex and
and regrettably
in order to get the required heat output
to heat the building and the swimming
pool
you're left with very few other options
than and i actually installed in
andrew's boiler and andrew's heated
um air handling equipment um and i just
wish that there were other ways of doing
it but at the moment there aren't
economical ways and certainly heat pumps
or a
thermal demand such as a leisure center
is
some way off thank you
councillor
thank you chairman um i meant to ask
this the previous committee actually
escaped my mind totally
i'm switching onto the footpath now for
the prom park
which is i'm reading it to take to be
the whole length of the entrance road
leading right in and i was just looking
at a figure of 25 000.
um that sounds pretty good to me it's
just i'm conscious having such on the
local highways panel of what things can
cost so so do we feel that sort of
accurate costing there because we're
talking about dedicated footpath which i
take it will take the prams and buggies
mobility scooters and everything we'll
have low level bollard lighting along
its length that's the way i read it
i'm just you know i'm not doubting
anyone but i just wondered how we
arrived at that price and what surface
will it be we're talking obviously a
hard surface
footpath element i assume
um
yes as i understand it the bollards and
the
path really go together as a sort of for
safety purposes as a risk assessment
um and
the road surfaces well i look at it
frequently and it doesn't match
underneath the top surface which is
cracking up
um but uh perhaps mr holmes would have
something to say on those items
uh thank you chairman um i don't have
the uh i wasn't involved in the
preparation of the the the budget for
this but um i know that mr uh our motors
team would have investigated that and
come up with a an estimate um so i'm
fairly confident what they've asked for
will be sufficient yes oh that's good
well yes i'm just thinking of local
highways panel history thanks
that was on the um
the budget
oh
sorry
thank you mr chairman uh right the the
one of the first things that brings to
minds with um the electric vehicles is
are the batteries on lease
or are they owned because i know a lot
of these batteries when they go wrong
they can be very very expensive to um
replace um i know somebody bought a
brand new range rover and the range
rover said they didn't charge the
batteries correctly they're not they
don't um lease them so it cost them 20
000 pounds to replace the batteries
so that's something that i think we
should look into
and this pontoon is it the one we
discussed gifting to the town council um
that they just do the crabbing on or is
this another pontoon
is it that one
yeah because i i know when this came up
with the cost of it we support we just
gift it to the town council and they can
do what they like but according to this
the report has changed and now we're
under a duty to repair it is that right
the duty to repair would be under
because of safety reasons wouldn't it no
no
i in the previous report
um it wasn't
we didn't have to repair it we we
discussed the option of just gifting it
to the town council and saying what you
like with it but this report seems to
suggest
that we
it's compulsory that we repair it
i think we certainly came to conclusion
that um whether the town council wanted
to have anything to do with it or not um
it still needed to be
put in good order
um
exactly that it's an asset of the
council it needs repair regardless of
who owns it and i personally feel if
we're going to make that offer to move
it on to the town council it should be
made in in the spirit of it's in good
order before that actually happens so
that's why rather than pass on that
liability effectively right and is it
only the
ferry the privately owned ferry that
uses it
at the moment we have that ferry that
uses it but there are other ideas and we
have been discussing an outline
potential could we not get the ferry
owners to foot the bill
i'm just looking thinking why are we
funding it sorry for my my burnham
um why are we funding something if we
don't use it the public don't really use
it only a private company uses it um i'm
sure council stamp would be able to
reinforce how much it is used but it is
used by a small ferry company but it's a
small company it's a local business how
much do we earn out of it how much they
can if we're going to spend 60 grand
like the park car parks we had a cough
with the cost but we get a massive
amount of revenue
what do we get off of the pontoon uh
very little very chairman but i would
say it's an asset a public asset used by
you know people children um for crabbing
so it's it's a local facility but um it
doesn't generate a huge income at this
moment in time but there is always the
opportunity to explore that but i don't
think the ferry is a is the major player
in the world so there's no real cost
benefit this is just uh effectively a
vanity loss
there are two aspects one about
preserving it because it's an important
aspect for the town but uh also it's one
of those one of the number of projects
which
where um
we will be looking to generate more
income in future
um which will be necessary but in some
cases
we'll have to invest in order to try and
increase future income streams
council thompson
but it is a very quick one um
i'm assuming that if we didn't repair or
replace it we would have to take it away
because of the health and safety aspect
but that would be a not inconsiderable
cost i would imagine so we're not just
looking at
this cost we're looking at this cost as
against yes taking it away and it is a
facility
thanks sorry
counselors
just to go very quickly for the comfort
of councillor miss white i've looked on
the john deere website
and the electric gator is actually
powered by eight six volt lead acid car
batteries effectively so ordinary
batteries not the dreaded lithium so
thank you
right but the um
obviously the cost of
buying as opposed to leasing batteries
is a consideration
well just in defense of the pontoon i
can understand where councillor white
might be coming from but it is an asset
and actually when i saw those photos
of what i would call the rust and
obviously authority can't afford to have
any risk of liability for anything
should something happen
it is good to see investment in burnham
on crouch and that is an asset that
would be a shame to lose because
i know what it could be used for now i
mean there is the the taxi so or the
ferry rather
there's the children's cabin there are
other vessels i've seen um pull up
against it people you know getting on
board boats or whatever and you do have
to think of the long term in the future
it would be a great loss if if that
pontoon wasn't there actually
fundamental lost burnham and crouch in
my opinion so i was glad to see that and
the rus um the pictures of the rust
indicated me work does need to be done
okay
then we better move on to um
we have four items here didn't we
four different elements in this
which page where's the start of this
page investment strategy index three
what's the page
page i don't have a page
83
83
oh my appendix 3 then the investment
strategy report um
mr leslie can you just summarize on that
i gave the intro at the start um to
cover them all i think thank you too yes
okay
um
does anybody want to comment on the
investment strategy report
um
likewise with the minimum revenue
provision statement let's see
okay so
there were four recommendations to
council on page
87
recommendations
right i better just confirm that
right
the um
now the recommendations were the
committee considered and reviews the
report
and the attached appendices and approves
for recommendation to council
for 2223 on 24th february
and to the council the following are
approved capital strategy appendix one
the capital project bids appendix two
the investment strategy appendix iii and
the minimum revenue provision statement
appendix four
right so um
we go and then to item eight
discretionary fees and charges
22 23 page 87 onwards
okay cheer i'll make it a just a quick
uh introduction on this one uh
the report came to members in january
with the fees and charges since uh
january there have been two changes
one to the high key parking which
remains unchanged now in this report
and the other one was to make sure that
the coach parking was was aligned with
the other
car parking charges both those two
aspects have been updated now and the
rest of the report remains the same as
that in january obviously they set out
the detailed discretionary fees and
charges
for the council
right
um
do you have any
questions counselor lagan
yeah thank you chair um
there's questions and observations i
think
i think this this report's missed the
point
um
the 116 pounds that's been uh included
in as the current charges on the highest
key have never been collected
um
that included vat so it's in here but
it's not been collected historically
so historically the barge owners have
considered that that fee
as has been encompassed as part of their
warfage
now i know that as a fact as a next
barge owner
we always used to get uh two car parking
spaces on the key and the river bailiff
uh gave us two
uh car parking tickets that we could
park on when we're using the vessels
and there's a fundamental difference
between a key and a car park and we've
got to be really clear on these members
because this is where the strategy gets
very very blurred
a working key the key mould has been
working for hundreds of years okay the
cargo's changed the cargo is now people
people that are bought in into malden
topsail charters as an organization
alone we're bringing in over 10 000
people into the town
now many of those parked at town car
parks so they made us a lot of money
so these people who are bringing in
people uh to the town uh and are running
heritage assets
that they're not running pleasure
cruises they're running heritage assets
where most of the money is reinvested
into the vessels which means it's
reinvested into the town
then they bring that money in
so we've got to get away from looking at
this as a car park um there's an
inconsistency in the report if if
members
members look at point 3 11 and it talks
about the recommendation too um which
little two talks about um the proposal
about the high key parking appendix c be
consulted upon and i just want to talk
to about appendix c in a moment
i brought back to the council et cetera
et cetera with a view to implementing
proposed new fees and charges from the
1st of october 2022.
uh it's in conflict with in conclusion
44.2
which doesn't really talk of that
they also talk in on page 111 which is
appendix c i think we need to be really
mindful here
because the inconsistencies in this
report i'm just scrolling down to page
111 so just bear with me
uh members it it talks about unregulated
well it's not unregulated because there
is an agreement
that's gone on for for many many years
so it's not been an unregulated
agreement with no formal agreements um
we say we're talking that the second
line to rectify and minimize the legal
challenge from third parties well i
think under custom and practice the
operators there could actually put a
legal challenge under customer practice
to us
so we need to be really mindful so what
i think we need to do is we need to
spend more time on this i think we need
to spend
more correspondence and liaising and
listening to the actual operators that
are down there and remember members
we're talking about a key not a car park
a key has sails it has crews come along
it has uh delivery trucks for for fuel
for these vessels so you can't chuck in
loads of car parks and worry about
people moving them there so the
commercial strategy in my is flawed at
the moment
so i think what we need to do is to
amend recommendation number two which is
what i'm going to propose in a moment
um to to to basically say i'm going back
up to that
marginally members for the tiredness of
my scrolling
um yeah it says you know it says that
the proposed on the heart appendix c be
consulted upon the separate report back
to council by the strategy resources
committee
i think that's that's what we need to do
i don't think we should say with the
view to implementing proposed new fees
and charges from october the 1st 2022 i
think we need to get a sound strategy
with the operators and all the key
stakeholders
talk to them
okay don't just try and impose something
on a commercial strategy that can just
raise us revenue because one barge
moving away from malden if you take this
50 person license
three people per car 60 cars that's 50
quid a day we're going to lose out so
the more we deter people to come the
more financially incurred we're going to
be
so i think it's a sound strategy to talk
to the people and look
what is available for to support those
individuals because i know that they
will be prepared to
to pay to keep their businesses viable
to protect the heritage of the town so i
propose that to members that we amend a
little too on the recommendations and we
go away and we continue to consult
with the stakeholders that are included
so thank you for your time members um
yes councilman can we before we come to
try to thinking about amending that to
can we take any more
discussion on that on that um
burt can you hear councillor fluke yes
yes thank you very much chairman we can
thank you
um
i i think this actually does
um
yes
um would it meet your um requirements if
we deleted the last phase of that
recommendation too yes the resources
committee yes it would chair because i
here i hear what council fluker says and
i'm still very mindful about councillor
fluker saying if the barges can go
something else will take their place
um
which i still am baffled by that
statement um but that's in the past i
suppose um i would be more than happy to
to do that because i think chair that
this gives us the time and the clarity
to engage with those individual
stakeholders and not turn around and say
we will impose this at this date because
it may roll on a little bit longer there
may be other initiatives that can go
forward but i do think we should say
we should say we should bring this back
to the resources there's also a major
side issue to this and that is
the question of parking on the hive by
the public
um which is be
which um
is being taken up with the cpp
um because uh if if that is that would
change the whole situation there
particularly if we have got any
additional businesses um using that area
so this this question of public parking
along that stretch from the queen's head
is um it would
make a different situation i think chair
just just to come back very quickly i
apologize members but you've got to look
at this differently you've got to look
at like the queen's head of a commercial
arrangement the queen's head don't pay
warface
the princess is completely different
you're not measuring eggs with eggs
you've got to look at it separately
i would be very happy if you amended
that if members agree to remember that
second part
thank you chairman
i was quite pleased to see this
recommendation actually from where we
were at the last meeting because i think
councillor swain you mentioned the heist
key as well and we did initially say to
come back with a report to this meeting
and actually i'm quite pleased to see
that there's going to be a time period
to consult with the barge owners and i
saw the issue of a separate report all
these aspects i think that councillor
lagan's referred to i would anticipate
that during sitting around the table
which i anticipate is going to happen a
lot of these issues would come out and
be discussed and then that separate
report would cover a multitude of things
um and then
on the basis of what might come forward
in recommendations then we can consider
that time so i would hope it is a very
full report that covers the aspects that
council leggings raised
in terms of the parking that's how i
read it actually that a lot would be
covered it wasn't just going to be
hurried now
um and come back to this meeting i when
i read that i was quite um warmed by it
to see that it's going to be a period of
time with the barge operators to discuss
matters and it's it's a question of how
what consultation means and how that's
carried out isn't it
so shall i move uh from the chair that
we delete that last phrase oh so sorry
councillor
yeah i hear what everyone's saying and i
certainly agree with it i just don't
think it i think it's a good idea to
have some kind of deadline something to
aim at
so i would actually amend the last
phrase or suggested councillor lagan
would agree um
with a view to
implementing a new strategy on fees and
charges from october the first i think
it does need looking at it needs
consultation but i wouldn't like to see
it wandering on forever
i'd just like to sit closer could
counseling
well unless i'm misreading this it's a
bit of an odd recommendation isn't it
because on the one hand it's saying
let's consult with
the barge operators and then it's saying
with a view to implementing the new fees
so that's a strange kind of consultation
because it appears that the decision has
already been made yes so um
i agree that um that we should remove
that uh final line uh but um perhaps
change it to to read with a view to
implementing a new strategy
sorry did you know that yes um i agree
with you right thank you
right so um
council megan you raised us sicily um
how would you formulate this change then
uh well i did do exactly what counselor
thompson what counselor none have said i
just had used them in that little part
so the end to say strategy interview to
adopting a new strategy a new strategy
in relation to
well okay relationship yeah
a new strategy yeah because you've also
got to realize that there's within the
negotiation there's been talk of ampr
number plate recognition systems being
set up on the key
yeah so come on let's let's get around
the table with these guys and give them
some credit yes okay right well we seem
to have a an agreed amendment to this um
is that generally agreed
yeah great thank you
chairman sorry can i just confirm we're
taking the date off that recommendation
yes
you're just adding the word strategy
with a view to implementing a new
strategy
thank you thank you for the
clarification
um right um anything
more on this
particular
yes councillors
again we have um very very emotive
discussion about fees
because
is
this
but you know these companies
these these the operators are businesses
my proposal would be
to be fair
by inflation
because the costs maintain the key to
going up inflation
um there will come a time
peace
um
well
um when you say discount um
that's part of the issue isn't it what
is it discounted from and
the base on which is discounted would be
part of
the discussion about the whole issue of
charging for
barge operators wouldn't it
come back
um
companies house
these businesses
are trading
okay well we'll come come to that
proposal in a minute council lady
yeah and um
thank you chair thank you members to let
me come back um there's a couple of um
flawed statements in in councillor
floof's statement there about the the
benchmarking exercise because the
benchmarking exercise that was under
done with wharf which was under done
with places like shotley marina
uh saint catherine's dock in london and
in malden you tire against the concrete
wall and slap a rope on a bollard and
you might get a bit of water and
electricity so we're not measuring eggs
with eggs that counts the fluka
i think
i don't actually disagree
with um increasing
by inflation um for the barge owners but
i don't think we should sit here in this
this committee and turn around and drop
another little bombshell on them i think
what we should do is uh leave and with
the support that we've given
which is which is a good level of
support but i go back to the amount of
revenue and amount of tourism that they
bring into the district and from next
year within our fees and charges apply
the rate of inflation
for a period of five years and then
review
those prices at that time i think that
allows surety and individuals to be able
to plan for their businesses it shows
we're being fair and equitable and we're
supporting the heritage assets that are
on the key
and they are a unique
part of our history we sit in this
chamber looking at papers they've got
logos on the top of them you look behind
the top table you see the assets there
and the assets on balance sheets would
be because they're quite expensive
assets so they're worth a few
okay thank you
i think the question of
um comparison with other places is all
part of um reviewing consultation
and the strategy for
um full barges um it is an important
aspect of it i think um so can we take
councillor fluker's proposal then this
is just for the current budget then
inflation increases
i just have to come back because i do
like the enjoyment that sometimes i'm
not supporting counselor flu because
proposal in any way perform i'm i'm
supporting
a fair and equitable measure within an
individual business next year and uh
well we we can agree to disagree
councillor because i i'm set here i'm
still i will listen to the tape but then
i don't want to take these assets away
but i think it's a fair fair fair thing
for us to to to reach i'm sure the bar
joiners would understand that but don't
forget not every vessel is a commercial
entity there's two vessels that are
operated by trusts down there yeah okay
thank you um
yes mr leslie points out that we really
should only be talking about the
increase in fees for this next budget
year
rather than talking about
for the future so can can we
amend that that we say we want the want
to increase the fees for 22-23 by rate
of inflation which is what has happened
in nearly all the other cases of
increased fees
it's been can i just say the car parks
actually and that's what i'm looking at
appendix uh can't read now appendix b
actually the most the car parks except
for hive key parking are not going up
it's only the prom park that we've now
bringing into line
i would much prefer to see let us have
this consultation let's listen sit
around the table and let that come back
chairman i um and then that i think um
what could happen is like halfway
through the year or whatever i don't
know i'm not going to
see any you know judge anything but i
think it's important to get that whole
report the separate report back covering
the aspects the proposal of council
thompson's which i thought had been
agreed by the committee um and moved on
but okay
we have we have two separate ones is
this request for a report um for on a
future strategy
and the other more specific one from
councillor fluker that we um increase
the fees for 2223 by the rate of
inflation
right
um
sorry
can we council fluke's proposal i'm not
sure it's been seconded no can i make a
proposal that we we recommend that the
um
one is proposed and
accepted by the members uh as part of
the recommendations detailed on the
paper please chair um second
which was the first one i think we need
to do what's on the table okay so
there's flickers first on the table yes
yes that's right
um
well we had recounting the the
amendment
um to eliminate the deadline and call
for a new strategy as having been passed
um we now need to to um
a second different council flukers um
now i'm sorry chair there's been a
proposal raised by myself which has been
secured by council and none of that
um proposal for fees for 22.3 to go by a
rate of inflation has been seconded can
we have a vote on that we're just
talking about shooters can we recall
that though please chair thank you
um okay
recorded vote then please tara
i need a second effort
seconder for the recording yes seconded
okay right okay tara
so it's it's for against the
amendment um of councillor fluke was
seconded by councillors durham that the
barge fees increased by the rate of
inflation for 22-23
i'm being thick please please apologize
uh i apologize so council fluker just
wants to agree
uh the little one two little one that we
agree what it says but at the rate of
inflation is that right council fluker
from 22-23
that's
so chairman in respect to the recorded
vote are we just voting on the amendment
to the appendix
and or are we actually going to vote on
the well
which was meant to be a vote on
council fluker's recommendation
concerning
the increase in fees for 22-23
suggest that the appendix be amended to
increase the barge fees by the rate of
inflation
okay oh i see amending amending point
one the detailed fees in charge has set
out he agrees
um
uh except yeah just agreeing that
amendment would not actually agree in
the whole no
that's what it would be right do we
agree this amendment to
the first amendment for first
recommendation for the detailed fees and
charges i've set out in pending safe
accept that
the barge fees be increased by the rate
of inflation
that's my understanding chairman it's
purely that we're amending the barge
fees to the right increase by the rate
of inflation and then subject to that
being agreed or not we would then vote
on the agreement of the appendix yes
yes
okay right so
so you're happy for me to take recorded
vote chairman recorded vote on the
increase thompson
i'm really sorry chairman but can i ask
what exactly right which rate of
inflation we're talking about because it
changes all the time and i'm sure mr
leslie has a point in time at which it's
fixed and could he please tell us how
much that is yes
could you tell us that would have been
very helpful chairman what the amount is
now and what we're talking about council
mrs thompson we've already voted an
amendment recommendation too but this
isn't
um
this is not an amendment for
recommendation one it is a motion in
itself really
to um
a recommendation itself sorry
to provide that clarity
should i just provide the clarity around
that yes
yes
certainly uh we use is 3.2 percent to be
consistent with the others i think
that's that's documented in one of the
dependencies as well it talks about the
inflation thank you yeah sorry can i
come back how much are we talking about
for a barge ish
what is three percent of seventeen
hundred quid
okay thank you
six six parties
all right
let me take it as a separate motion then
the barge fees be increased
by a rate of inflation for 22-23
okay yes
those are and you wanted a recorded vote
on this
i don't know i don't think you can take
it as a separate motion i think you need
to take it as an amendment
and then then vote on that amendment and
if that amendment fails then we vote on
the original or an an adjusted like
shall we leave it in the past until we
finish talking about the other appendix
if there are any more questions to be
raised on
i think we're taking it as amendment as
councillor says and i think tara just
needed to call out the names and then
well it's sort of remembered
yeah he was taking it as an amendment i
believe
that that's fine council what council of
the fluke has raised
an amendment to
recommendation two little one
and that is that's the amendment that
council fluke has made so that amendment
we need to vote on that yes um as and
i've asked for a recorded vote she's
been seconded by councillor none so if
if that fails then we go back to this or
another record whatever we do but we
must vote on that as councillor fluka uh
has raised whether maybe these this
should be other amendments
there can be further amendments sorry we
deal with this amendment once and then
that then becomes a substantive motion
and then we move on
and this is just one amendment there may
be other yes this is just the one
amendment so the amendment to your
appendix one
an amendment okay
amendment two
recommendation little one
then um yeah to increase the barge fees
by the rate of inflation all right thank
you and okay if you're called forward
against that then
yes members if you can indicate four
against rob stone please when i call
your name starting the council mrs
channel please
don't
counsel durham ball
council fluker
that's the laggin
against
that's a nun
against
policy
against
that's the stamp
against
council stevens
against
chairman of the results that are four
four five against and two abstentions so
that that that is lost chairman that
amendment thank you thank you
right could have any further comment on
um appendix a then the fees and charges
yeah i'd like to retract my proposal and
i recommend them i meant my proposal to
accept the recommendation too little one
as detailed in the agenda papers
um
well this is
yeah well if nobody nobody wishes to
make any further comment on fees and
charges
um i'll take uh
councillor lagan's move to pass that
recommendation
great thank you
we've already dealt with um
with little two
all right thank you can we move on to
item nine then
medium term financial strategy
on
page
starting page one one three
okay thank you
uh following on from uh the all member
briefing i gave in january the figures
remain uh unchanged and
you can see the areas are now coming
forward in formal reports in terms of
the figures i provided at the time
table 1 of the report in section 4
details the budget
changes over the next three years and
the increase in the budget gap forecast
they're in
next year a drawdown from the general
fund balance of
452 000 pounds is included in the budget
with this rising to 1.6 million by
25 if no action is taken and assumptions
remain the same
this is despite a five pound increase in
cancer tax included in the forecast
table two provides a summary of the
growth items included in the forecast
with the detail at appendix 2 these
remain unchanged from those presented to
the committee back in january
paragraph 6.1 attempts to quantify the
impact that kovid has had on the
council's ongoing financial position
and shows a potential impact of 700 000
pounds next year as a result
table four shows that the council's
projected general fund balance based on
the funding gaps
shows that by the end of 24-25 the
balance would fall below the rebecca
amended minimum level of 2.6 million
pounds although balances are currently
sufficiently high to manage a drawdown
next year the increasing gap and ongoing
need to draw down reserves will need to
be addressed quickly
thank you mr leslie um
yes clearly the
figures um and the diagram after the
next year are
alarming
um
but obviously that's um
in a do-nothing situation so it it
um it builds in certain things that we
can be fairly sure of but there are a
lot of uncertainties um and mr leslie
could recite all of those
um
but
it does point out that we need
both to
generate more income and also to improve
the capital um capital reserves
um
so uh
comment from members and
councillor thompson
thank you chairman um
yeah i accept everything that's said um
and i
i'd like to say i'm more than happy but
i'm not happy because i don't like the
look of the figures but yeah i would
certainly accept the recommendation the
only thing i would say and i'm not
planning anything clever is that should
circumstances change drastically between
now and count you know the actual budget
meeting i might need to change that but
as things are i certainly accept the
recommendation thank you
thank you
logan yeah thanks chair um first of all
mr lizzie thanks for a really um concise
and and good report for for
non-financial brands like myself do you
think that there would be any more
funding and i'm that you i'm asking you
to get a crystal ball here um from the
cove of release pressures do you think
central government would release
anything in the next one two years that
may come forward to help
i don't believe there will be any more
covered pacific support provided from
what already has been provided
the question mark about funding for me
is around the service delivery grant
which is worth about a hundred thousand
pounds
uh that's really only a one-year grant
we don't know where that's going to go
and how it's going to be distributed
next year we've had a one-year local
government finance settlement again so
we have that uncertainty so that's
potential area where we could could
benefit also the new homes bonus is
another area the consultation around the
new homes bonus um has been out and
feedback uh has come back so we're
waiting to see what shape that will take
going forward clearly we've got nearly a
million pounds of new homes bonus within
our funding for next year so how that
shapes will be very important for us
going forward we're projecting that that
falls um by about uh two to three
hundred thousand pounds um for us next
year it has been the highest level of
new homes bonus we've ever received
next year so that's clearly a volatility
risk for us it could be better or it
could be worse i see those as a key
government funding
areas in terms of the local funding
business rates and how that shapes will
be another
one for us as well to watch and how our
businesses
develop
certainly in terms of collection rates
um although there are some signs that
the economy is recovering and we're
starting to pick up lost arrears from
from past years as well so i see those
as the main areas
thank you very much
uh councillor darren
well thank you
chairman i mean these figures are very
sobering aren't they and um we're not
alone in this certainly all um local
government is facing the same thing we
wanted a three-year settlement we didn't
get it
we have a one-year settlement
i i honestly
don't believe that there is going to be
any additional money coming from the
government and certainly with the
leveling up white paper today firmly
indicating that the government began to
put more money into the midlands and the
north and and not concentrate as much on
on the south i don't think we can
we can rely on anything um and you know
we are under inflationary pressures and
we're under pressures from the increase
in national living wage etc etc and i'm
afraid the co the cold facts of life are
we we either have to raise more income
and and that's our
opportunity to do that is fairly limited
um we have to find efficiencies and uh
certainly
the low-hanging fruit in terms of
efficiencies was picked long long ago
or we have to look very much at the
services
and we have to look at um
how we deliver our services to our
residents uh and
you know i we can't unfortunately rule
out reductions in services and cuts
we have to be
realistic i'm afraid but it's that it's
very sobering
yes cindy yes that's a channel oh well
just that's him and i thought that was a
very good report um i have to say i
thought it was easy to agree with
council again easy to read and i
actually was reading i think the clear
message
that mr leslie was giving um in that as
the 151 officer yes and highlighting the
concerns and what it would mean
if we don't do really a sustainable
budget now we have to balance the budget
we're talking about sustainable here as
well i believe and where that would end
up if we don't perhaps act um sensibly
at this point in time
regarding because when you look at the
graph
that we've all i'm sure seen i think you
can see quite frankly where we are
headed in that time period and in the
three years as mr leslie has pointed out
what could happen
um we and as a 151 officer he is clear
we have to have the 2.6 million there so
i thought it was an excellent report
thank you
yes it sort of emphasizes we need to
try and balance the budget for the
company the next year
23 four
council fluker
perhaps
now
in terms of fairly short term um
possibilities for
efficiency or reducing costs but also
there are a number of
bigger projects um that are being looked
at which
would generate capital for future
capital budgets um and which should also
improve increa
yield some future incomes from various
types whether they match up to the
requirement it's not better but there's
a number of things that are being looked
at including major ones
capture step
yeah thank you i'm going to look for mr
holmes to help on this one if he's still
there
and what council focus said is
absolutely spot on but i'm not sure how
much can be said in in council about
this building uh i think conversations
have taken place i think councillor
durham's on it council fluker started it
i think when he was the leader when i
was the leader we were discussing it and
i totally agree with what he's actually
said and i'm sure because i've been
trying to make sure it comes to council
because i'm a great advocate these
decisions need to come to council as
soon as possible and not small working
groups of a chosen few
and i think that needs to come through
very quickly to council and i would urge
um mr holmes or whoever if they can look
at that or the new leader actually i'm
so sorry councillor channel you're the
new leader so if i'm sorry it wasn't
being rude um
if that could actually come to council
very soon because i'm i was little being
a little bit flippant there she knows i
wasn't meaning it but i think it's
really important and he makes a very
good point the working practices have
changed and we have been looking at it
and i know that there's some officers
done a great deal of hard work behind
the scenes and one's actually sitting at
the back i think um and it does need to
come to council it's no good as just
having working groups and meetings if
we're not going to bring a paper to
council so i actually do agree on the
odd occasion with council of luca um
perhaps perhaps i can actually defer to
mr holmes to to um how far we can what
we can say on on major projects in case
i say too much
would you want me to
thank you chairman yes absolutely
there's corporate projects working group
is looking at a number of projects
including some major projects and some
of them obviously are commercial at this
time but nonetheless um there will be a
report to council and a briefing is
actually being arranged for members
ahead of that so that we can bring all
members up to date
give you an assurance it's a very early
stage we're exploring options
particularly around this building i
think it's fair and open to say that you
know we recognize that there's a
potential options around this site so
all that will be coming for members um
but through through the working group
and then back back to back to council
council
just to say chairman thank you for that
mr holmes and council stamps fine by
saying what she did because
i think um she would know probably we do
think alike on some things we've had
i've had similar conversations in fact
i've had conversations recently about
working groups and i have a view on
working groups but i also have a view on
making sure all members
are informed and things are done in
council that need to be done in council
chairman
yes
um
well council white i think
not my fault
budget statements if i've been elected
we are going to run on a more financial
basis we're going to balance our books
we're going to increase our revenue
we've been fine and then all of us i am
just as bad as every other member have
our own pet projects and we always say
but we just need this 60 000 or 100 000
for this project and we had to supply
this for free for that project and i
just think that looking at these figures
we've got to get real it's like our own
um bank account so something i think
although we want to give that away we
really do have to run this on a
financial basis and we do have to
increase revenue oh we're going to go
back up that's that's the facts that
matter
um and then then we'll have another gold
district council and we need to keep
mold district council because it's
important so we need to get our
offending within our budget which
unfortunately we're not very good at
doing and i say i have my own management
projects so i can't talk it's not you
know any one thing um
and also every time this comes up we're
always told um no we're gonna have to
start freezing anymore so and then every
six months that's overruled and we we
have a lot more staff that's that's one
thing that always happens
um we've had officers who are going to
increase revenue
but so far i don't think the revenues
increased any more than what the wages
are and so i think we need a really
in-depth look at this to try and get
this on a basis where we're actually
going to see that the council is going
to be running like a private company to
some extent and make an income not just
through car parking and not just through
planning which is the two usual ones for
increasing fees but we need to be really
strategic and we need to to see what
bank for our buck we're getting you know
uh maybe we think is this financially
viable if it is not we have to stop
doing it
you know we we need to get tough to keep
this council here we must keep molten
district council financially sound and
so far we're going through money in a
range of knots i don't know what the
answer is but let's all pull together
and try and fix it if we can
yes um i would say that
through through various um recent
snrs and
finance working groups we have
constantly paired um items off the
agenda
expense expenditure items and where
um
[Music]
staff have been taken on it's
really to be able to maintain the
service that we're committed to um
but uh
you're quite right but whether whether
one should really look upon the district
council certainly as a commercial
business is a another a more wider wider
point but but we we also have to be
careful that we're still here we haven't
spent it's not just about being a
corporate we have to suddenly think if
we've got
a million pounds to spend we have to get
within that budget somehow we have to do
it so we don't go back yes yes we have
to do some fairly fundamental changes
okay thank you counselors
and commercially sensitive i still think
that it should come back
just to help
um
right mtfs the recommendation that the
updated mtfs strategy for 22 23 to 24 25
as of today's date appendix won't be
approved
agreed right thank you then
[Music]
um that we want uh item 10
with which is on page 175 75
revised um
2122 estimates the original 22 23 budget
and the um
council tax
considerations for 22-23
well okay if you agree to put those
through to cancel them
treasury management strategy
there's nobody nobody is querying that
then okay
yes
along the lines that we've been talking
about as section one five one officer
and uh was that in the imperfectif or
the minimum revenue statement
somewhere i think it said in this mdfs
so that's
statement as
section one five one officer should be
attended
yes all of that chairman but i have just
had a message from a member of the
public excuse me meeting chocolate
um who can't hear a word counselor
fluker is saying
there may be those out there who are
grateful
this particular acquaintance um i don't
invent something make a difference if
cancer fluke has sat down near that
thing with you absolutely
anyway thank you for letting me button
let's apologize chairman gentlemen i
think councillor thompson needs to take
a foot off the cable to stop
thank you
just to
get off the finance for a moment a
review of memorials and cemeteries um
this is going to be a report's going to
be from mr holmes
thank you chairman uh members recall the
last meeting you looked at this report
and asked for some additional details
and some consultation to be carried out
and since that time debbie hori our
cemetery's officer has been undertaking
that work um and uh mr is on the line
now on i think she will actually give
members the update on the information
they were seeking
thank you
miss hurry okay
the um so since the report was presented
um last month i've had an opportunity to
consult with the friends of haybridge
cemetery
and with carly mace who's the chair of
malden um friends group and we've been
able to
um add a couple more recommendations
um
most of the report has remained
unchanged other than the main
differences being that we're
recommending that
the least period be for 10 years rather
than for five years
and that we're very clear
that the new scheme is um
is talking about benches that we're
going to install moving forward and not
going to be looking at things
respectively so it won't affect people
who have purchased a bench
um in the district up until now the only
time we would look to
to remove those benches would be if they
had fallen into disrepair and that would
be after testing them with our new
scheme in place
everything else is kind of remaining the
same
um
mr holmes that doesn't uh nothing that
mr horace mr said uh alters the
recommendations we've got on the agenda
does it
no those recommendations have been
crafted around and include the comments
that just been made
you have some comments um
councillor channel well not a comment
chairman um i think it may have been
covered by the officer actually because
i read the report and i wasn't quite
clear what had come out of the
discussions um with the friends of um
haybridge and also carly maye is the
chairman of the malden one so regarding
the points you've just made they were
the only things really that were
critical out of that consultation so
we've encompassed really every thinking
that the uh friends groups came up with
and they're happy with the proposals as
are because i think you said um in the
report it mentions you shared the report
with them ahead of going to this
committee so could we just have
confirmation on that
yes absolutely they've um they've seen
the report and put recommendations in
and moving forward
and we're going to make sure that there
is always proper consultation with the
friends groups um and we're in talks at
the moment setting up regular
meetings um with the operations manager
myself and the friends group to make
sure that anything that happens within
the centuries they are properly
consulted with
okay cancer channel
counseling yes
um yes thank you um a good report and
obviously very um thoroughly
investigated i just feel i do need to
say this though that um it's important
talking to the friends group
groups but they're not the be all and
endor
the most important people here are the
bereaved
and
we shouldn't underestimate the
sensitivity of this particularly as it
relates to roman numeral ii
and from a historical point of view of
course these plaques are a historical
record
and you've only i mean i know we're not
responsible for these particular
ventures but you've only got to look at
the benches outside of all saints church
in malden to realize that that that's
the fact um that they are a historical
record so it concerns me a bit really
that this is almost kind of suggesting
that after 10 years we can kind of move
on with the bereaved uh and what happens
to these plaques and unless i've missed
it i'm not sure what's happening with
the plaques after the 10-year period
please thank you i'm not sure miss horry
weather was some idea that they would be
um moved to a different location but
still retained is that right
absolutely we would consult with family
so if after the 10-year period the
family no longer wish to leave to plaque
on to a bench we would consult with them
they would have the right to have them
returned to them but alternatively we
have a memorial war with mordon cemetery
we have the chapel wall in hayward
cemetery and a pergola in
burma crouch cemetery there's also talk
of memorial areas within promenade park
so we would be looking to keep the
plaques
um as as councillor nan rightly points
out they are a lasting memory of those
people and we wouldn't want to take
those away
what we're looking at is is having a a
system where we can make sure that the
benches that people are using all the
public are using are safe and fit for
purpose
um but certainly not getting rid of any
of the plaques
i'm very grateful for that reply thank
you thank you
councillor
okay counselor
thank you very much indeed again an
excellent report looking at the picture
on page
261 uh it certainly looks like a plastic
bench can we just have a look through
the report and it may well say it
that the
the plastic bench is made from recycled
plastic that would be uh
advantageous please i think that is the
idea isn't it yeah yeah no that's fine i
was
she's modding that's absolutely fine
yeah we certainly be looking to use the
recycled plastic benches where possible
and they are more environmentally
friendly and i think you'll agree from
the pictures that they they
look better than they sound
um but we have got a caveat in there
saying that certainly in certain areas
we would be open to consultation and i
think i'm sorry i missed that from that
was one of the key points that we
discussed with the friends group
that in certain areas particularly in
cemeteries or in
places of historical interest
there would be the option for
discussions but generally speaking we
would look to use the recycled plastic
benches
yeah but there's much less uh ongoing
maintenance and they last a whole lot
longer thank you very much
anymore um questions kevin councillor
thank you chair well again i'll conclude
with the fellow members um this sorry
the very very good report um and things
have moved immeasurably since you've
been in post so thank you for that
and i will say how i see it i i don't
like sharing benches
with plaques
i think that when somebody's bereaved
and they want to have um a memorial
for somebody who they've loved
maybe want to sit in a quiet place with
a and contemplate that person
you know you walk past some of the
benches and they've got bunches of
flowers on them you know those memories
to that individual person are very very
special
um and i understand the the purpose of
the report but i don't know i just think
i sometimes think my late mother and if
a couple of people who had passed away
at the same time if she was on a plaque
next to them she'd be wriggling around
in that i'll tell you that she wouldn't
be happy
um so i i'm i'm i'm a fan of of of
giving
solitude to a single place i know
there's complexities within that and i
think we do need to look at the
structure of the benches moving forward
but i really don't like and can't
support i'll be brutally honest with you
that the sharing of of of those
memorials on a bench for a set period of
time
um
it's a bit like the horse troughs in
more than half as you you know back in
the day if they've been thinking like
that we wouldn't have had those
so um while i get it i i it's it's very
uncomfortable with me and i i can't
support it
and well if i might just as we joined in
there the the crosstracks and things
like that were for the community weren't
they
well for the horses i think rather than
the people
yes they were but yeah it's it's that
yeah i'm sorry for being flippant
because that was that was uncalled for
but you know you know it's it's the
point he's a counselor as a nun has said
a very elegant thing about
the historical value to that but i go
from the emotional aspect of it
you know when you sometimes read some of
those things that people put on there
intensely intensely um personal to those
those families those individuals and
maldens as a family and burnham and all
the different areas in the in the
district we can't have benches every
five to six feet we know that i think we
we need to look at that strategy
memorial walls bricks those types of
things but if someone wants to have a
place of solitude
i think that's only right and respectful
in my eyes yes i think the um one of the
points of the approach is to
um have some control over where benches
go um
or from our part
um but it is it is very sensitive in
that um
uh
the
they are
what we say communal burial grounds
um and the
having privatizing through say an area
with a with a bench
uh is it is is a bit of a conflict it's
uh
conflicts with the communal aspect of um
and so sharing a bench is sort of
communal rather than bit being sort of
felt to be
some particular property in that area
council is down
yeah thank you i take on bulldog cancer
lag and i said i mean my late
father-in-law was put in there not that
long ago and
at some stage my dad will join him or
somewhere around there i'm just
wondering whether we can off give the
option of um
having a single plaque on a bench but
charging a premium for it
you know then then we then we you know
that we're offering a service to
everybody and you know i'm sure there
are people that would be quite happy to
to share a bench and therefore the costs
but if somebody's just somebody
desperately needs
a bench to themselves well then there's
a premium price to be paid for that i
think that's rather sort of buying um
space isn't it um
which which space would be rather
limited because there's obviously a
limit to the numbers of benches that's
practical to have
but
yes cancer performancy
okay
thank you um yeah i actually agree with
the council and councillor durham
um i i think if you want the bench and
you're quite prepared to pay for it i
don't know if anybody's been watching
afterlife in the series of afterlife
three
uh absolutely brilliantly written by
ricky gervais and and
touches on some very very um
um
what's the word
thank you sensitive points and and i
agree with council and again
i think i think the main point of this
is people won't buy the bench
the benches will be the district council
no they can buy the bench they they can
buy the bench they buy the bench in the
service
um and if you want if you're if you want
to buy your own bench and sit there i
think i think you should you would never
turn around and say nobody can sit on
this bench you're not going to turn
around if somebody wants to sit with you
and say you can't sit on it i've paid
for it it's it's to actually think about
um all over reminisce
enjoy whatever the feelings are at the
time and and and i anyway i agree with
council again
sorry um right um mr holmes do you have
so thank you should i say something
thank you chairman yes i'm sure um sorry
we'll comment but my understanding is
this is about um space now because
obviously we have a lot of demands for
memorial plaques if we have benches with
just one name on there's probably going
to be two or three other people who
won't be able to take advantage of that
so i think the idea being that we
actually allow more than one to actually
deal with advance which doesn't mean we
have to keep putting in more and more
benches and we are looking at other
options so you know there are memorial
uh pathways we're talking about and also
we've got the wall that was mentioned
but so i think we're trying to find a
balance give people options but um if we
start having exclusive benches again
with one plaque on even if it's premium
rate it won't help with us trying to
meet our demand i think that's that's a
concern
thank you chairman um yes i can see that
we're you know we're likely to be
inundated with benches um i believe i've
mentioned this at the last meeting um
and i i think this is an interim measure
um having you know three plaques on a
bench before we can maybe afford to have
memorial walls uh memorial paths etc um
going back to um uh previous speakers uh
you know the council might for instance
um you know we could we can't um do
these things if we can't afford them but
we can look
um to them in the future you know these
um other memorial options but i see this
very much this proposal as an interim
measure um until we can get those others
um underway
yes well i imagine that it is an option
um
and
uh
yeah
the the investment cost of something
like memory would in effect in the
longer term be covered by
payments for plaques and which were
removed to their councillor durham
thank you for letting me come back again
i think we just need to think about you
know why why people want
a plaque on a bench
now
is it because
there is no other
record of the fact that their remains
are in that
cemetery
because we have a new very very pleasant
um area where we're now entering uh
cremated remains
and there is the opportunity for
uh people to have a
headstone if you if you like there so
you know perhaps if they've if if a
family has that and has somewhere to go
and sit and their name is recorded
that would suffice there are others i
think perhaps that where the ashes are
just spread in the the flowers and and
in the rose beds and there are little
plaques as well
so i
i'm i'm in two minds here and and i
totally take on board the fact that if
there's one plaque per bench we're gonna
have too many benches
but if the price is priced accordingly i
think that will would control it um if
you have a high enough price
you're going to have a limited limited
take up of it but it still gives people
that option
if i is it okay for me to yes sure yes
um i think
what we've tried to do with this report
is to
um to think about those people who can't
necessarily afford to pay
over a thousand pounds and and by having
more than one plaque on a on a bench
it enables the cost to be much lower so
it's a scheme that's available for more
people than the current scheme that's in
place now
it's for cemeteries and for for all open
spaces and there's there's some areas
such as in current burial areas or
promenade park
where there's high demand for for
benches which we cannot meet and at the
moment we have waiting lists for people
and where we're unable to to put enough
benches in
and if you think about um in current
burial areas where there'll be a row of
grave spaces and there'll be
around about 12 grades in that row
if there's only going to lead to benches
that means more people are missing out
than those who are able to take
advantage of this scheme
so what we're hoping is that we'll be
able to accommodate more people
and so that they can have something
rather than a select few at the moment
so that's the idea behind it to to make
it an affordable option for people
um
as well as being able to accommodate
those people on the waiting list
um can we turn to the specific
recommendations that we have here um
um
and that the sale of benches as an
individual item available purchase which
are then installed in our parts and open
spaces cease
that a new scheme be introduced where
customers can lease a plaque on a bench
for 10 year periods
that the updated remorse and cemeteries
parks and open spaces policy depending
see be agreed and implemented no later
than first of april 2022
that the new scheme be introduced with
effect from first of april 2022
and will not be applied retrospectively
thank you mr man um just briefly um i
just think we should agree um this
option here i i do agree with it um but
two other options have come to mind one
is i know in the working groups we
discussed having um plaque trees for
putting the plaques on i wonder if we
could progress that further so
people can buy a branch to put their
plaque on
um and the other thing um because if we
need to increase the revenue
if we're short of space for for benches
we could
pick a a very large amount so that
people could buy a very expensive branch
for 10 or 20 000 and then that would
help cut our budget deficit
i'm not sure whether you mean a natural
tree or an artificial one with um
it was artificial the one that we but it
could also be real
yes well miss horry will probably think
about that absolutely
no it's absolutely i'm really glad that
you've mentioned that because we've got
some fantastic ideas that we want to
introduce into the cemeteries and one of
those does include a bronze memorial
tree and we're hoping in the next year
or so to have designated um scattering
areas we're looking to have woodland
view with one of those trees
but as i'm sure
you'll appreciate it's been difficult
the last couple of years
with the pandemic
and and getting on top of things but i
will certainly be looking forward to
coming back to speak to you all about
some of the great initiatives uh
columbariums memorial trees and other
things so to have as many options
available to our residents as we
possibly can
brilliant thank you
all right council
um
yeah thank you
the great benchmark is
absolutely
the
best
but also
raise the most
uh better city corporation particularly
in this world
i'd urge
and also
across
swear oh i think miss hurry then pops
out to make a trip to the city of london
cemetery
okay wonderful can i
come out to yourselves are you going to
the the funeral exhibition in june at um
stoneleigh because that's an exhibition
that has all of these things on display
i will be going but if you're
no i mean it is a good opportunity to to
look and see what is available for
memorials um at stanley in june thank
you
kevin councillor
thank you chair i
sit here slightly distasteful with some
of the comments that are made about
charging somebody 20 grand for a tree i
get the intent but
it's let's strip it right back to what
it actually is it's a memorial for
somebody who's died somebody who's
walked the earth who's loved and people
want to remember those individuals so
there should be a fair price but i'd
hate to see us try and commercialize the
hell out of this
i think what counselor durham said was
actually a good solution for everything
if if that was entered in and there
could be a structured fee
um and i'm not saying a premium of an
extortion amount of money i'm saying a
fair amount of money that somebody could
pay to have a single although in my mind
it does exclude people but it also gives
people like myself are not on the higher
end of the earnings scale the ability to
rent a plaque if necessary for for a
loved one so i think we just need to
tread a little bit carefully in the in
the debate um and i like the fact
there's all the other options that we're
going to have and how to memorialize
people
um but let's not strip it away from the
fundamentals this is about people at
their worst time
remembering somebody who's walked the
planet who was loved
okay okay none
well um
absolutely i was gonna say exactly the
same and we're not exactly the same but
very similar things um but can can we
then perhaps agree these recommendations
but with an amendment to little two
which which picks up on councillor
durham's suggestion
that actually um
a structured uh a theater fit as fee
structure is introduced which recognize
that recognizes um the volume of plaques
per bench
in other words
you you could actually um uh put a
plaque on a single plaque on a bench or
you could put a plaque on a bench with a
series of plaques
so some kind of structure to it
subjects yes subject to availability
effectively giving somebody the right to
pay to have a with their own soul plaque
on it isn't it it is yes
yeah exactly
well that's availability is the question
yes
councillor stevens
thank you chair and i think yeah you
just hit the nail on the head that
people would be paying to have some sort
of advantage over everybody else and i
know that happens in all sorts of things
but it feels uncomfortable to me in this
particular subject and as we've said
subject to availability so if you've got
one person that's perhaps prepared to
pay three times more for their own bench
and then you've got three people over
here who don't want to and they're happy
to share a bench but you've only got
space for one bench
now what do you do and i think we if we
were going to vote for that we'd need
that answer in place first thank you
yeah and i might come back if although
my comments might have been facetious
that's what i meant is that if somebody
wants their own bench it's going to have
to cost otherwise you're going to stop
several people having other benches it
has to be fair and there has to be a way
of splitting it
just take a comment if you want a
private plaque on a private bench it's
going to have to be you know certainly
more otherwise it will stop other people
who who can't afford their own bench
having any form of plaque at all yes i
think that's all all of the question of
availability of benches isn't it hope
casa thompson
thank you chairman um i think the rub is
in the
subject to availability unfortunately
you know it's a fact of life
that the number of people who we want to
remember can only ever increase um and
the space
seems to only have a decrease
i just
while i've got every sympathy with the
idea of having one plaque on a bench we
just i just don't see how we can do it
as part of the existing problem we're
looking for a solution for unless we
could have chairs of course
yeah
but um
i don't know is that even an option
you can have a single chair which would
cost a bit more than a bench or person
but
[Music]
thank you chairman i i think essentially
what we're saying is you know
demand outstrip supply
we if we start going down the route of
having exclusive one plaque one bench
we're going to be very quickly back to
where and we are now and i perhaps feel
that we should
be provide a scheme which is accessible
to all that people can afford and is
reasonable and i think you know you've
heard about the other options that come
up there will be other ways for people
to uh memorialize and some of those may
be more expensive than others but i
think as a basic bench with plaques it
should be as
open as possible and it would it would
cause us great difficulty in trying to
say yes we're going to put one name on
there for price and then other people
are turned away i feel um that will be
difficult for debbie to administer so
absolutely 100 right
cancer channel can one last comment yes
well thank you um i i think uh what
council shawnee said um
this is a scheme that's coming in but
clearly from what the office has said
we're gonna have looks at other things
and i've just googled some stuff on
memorials and actually
there's some almost is the wrong word
i've got to be careful what i say
because i've lost people but actually
it's quite exciting when you can see
some things that can be done to actually
have plaques on board in a smaller
smaller place so i think to go ahead
with this because i take the valued
point about i can see where counselor
darren was coming from but it does
concern me then other people will lose
out but it doesn't mean to say going
forward there might be an alternative
and that can be embraced later on but
with the other ideas coming forward so
i'm i'm content to go with the
recommendation as is recognizing the
officers um who have told us they're
looking at other means
for memorials and also then that might
allow the bench scheme to be adapted in
due course but i think for now i will
tend to go with the officer's
recommendation
and i'll second that
okay can i can i move all these
recommendations then
seconded by
council
why
okay
agreed yeah
can you uh record that i descend no i'm
not an agreement just for that certainly
just because tara okay record that
councillor
disagrees with the recommendation
yes of course chairman thank you
um right
item 13 any other item business is
urgent there is one which
was circulated earlier
um concerning new grant scheme new money
for grants have um
have come up um
so perhaps
mr leslie can you just
give us the rundown on that
thank you
cheer
so we've received uh additional funding
from government in light of the omicron
variant
the extra grant is for businesses so
that we can award further grants to
those who have been affected by
this particular predominantly those
reliant on social indoor mixing
hospitality leisure events
and the accommodation sector
for that these are discretionary
policies so we do require approval
in order to distribute those
the other area we receive grant for is
in the ability to award
business rate release to these
businesses
as well so this is essentially why we
have two policies here
today one is for grants for businesses
the other is to award relief
for
local businesses
we also have just to draw your attention
as well on page 19 of the supplementary
pack
there is
in paragraph 4.3 there is a percentage
figure still to be determined
this is in relation to the business
rates reliefs
how this will operate
is that we will have the applications
come through and we're looking to
maximize our grant allocation and the
amount we can give to those eligible
businesses and once we have a
idea of the number we will then
change the percentage accordingly of
course the idea being provide maximum
benefit to the local businesses
through
the scheme
on that part in terms of eligibility
each report sets out the eligible
businesses
in there we've got uh page 10 for
example paragraph three
tackles that as you can see it reflects
those
businesses which government has
highlighted as particularly impacted by
the omicron
variant the recommendation is also for
delegation to be given to vary these if
needed we do have a track record now of
distributing uh grants um i believe
quite effectively to those businesses
and being quite responsive uh
along the lines of amending the policy
so we've got that corporate knowledge
built up of who who may be in need and
who may be eligible but nonetheless we
like to be as flexible as possible so
that we can maximise those businesses uh
who need it so in short these policies
will allow us to get the
grants out to those businesses who need
it as soon as possible
chris please
um
um
yes i think i know the answer to this
but just for the record for the minutes
please could um mr leslie confirm that
parish councils are not eligible to make
a claim
for lost revenue uh for example in terms
of hiring of um of premises thank you
there are a number of schemes but uh if
i might just refer to uh ms lamar just
just to confirm
you know that's correct they are
ineligible
ineligible
thank you thank you
um
yeah thank you um
can i just say um well done for applying
the grants um for ever since kovid i
think this council has worked really
hard
some of the some of the staff have been
under tremendous pressure to try and get
them out
we showed a great deal of due diligence
by checking before we actually started
handing the money out because i know
that some councils did and then they had
to pay it back because they were so
quick to pay out so i'd like to
congratulate the council
and also again now is this information
and policy going to go on the website so
that the businesses are actually know
what they're doing because i'm i'm sure
councillor channel flookada and white
and everybody else sitting around here
lagum and everybody else um
i always call you lagam lagan don't i
always get you
so sorry oh god how long have i known
you
um
loads and loads of emails and inquiries
about grants so as long as this can be
really easy to find on the website it
will reduce our postbags tremendously so
but well done thank you very much please
note that i think all of us as
councillors
say thank you for doing that thank you
jay thank you i think we have continued
on this this kind of disbursement of
government grants yeah agreed
um
[Music]
right can i move these two
recommendations then
as
let's
the additional restrictions grant
policies appendix one is approved and
delegation is given to the director of
resources in consultation with the
leader of the council and the chairman
of the strategy and resource committee
to amend the policy to respond to
business need
but and secondly that the covered 19
additional relief fund policy at
appendix 2 is approved and delegation is
given to the director of resources in
consultation with the leader of the
council and the chairman of strategy and
resources committee to amend the policy
to respond to business need
right thank you very much
um
now we come to item oh well item 14
exclusion of the public and the press
um
uh to resolve that under section in 108
records for the local government at 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following items a business on
the grounds that they involve the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph three of part one
of schedule 12a to the act and that this
satisfies the public interest test
secretary councillor
agreed